J'ai écrit un livre sur elle, je l'ai illustré
et les choses que Ruby m'a apprises sont celles-ci.
Ruby m'a appris qu'on n'est pas censé avoir peur des bugs.
Et que même le plus gros des problèmes
est juste un groupe de petits problèmes les uns à côté des autres.
Ruby m'a aussi présentée à ses amis,
le versant coloré de la culture Internet.
Elle a pour ami le léopard des neiges,
qui est beau mais ne veut pas jouer avec les autres enfants.
Elle a des amis comme les robots verts qui sont très gentils mais désordonnés.
Et elle a des amis comme Linux le pingouin,
qui est impitoyablement efficace, mais quelque peu difficile à comprendre.
Et des renards idéalistes, et j'en passe.
Dans le monde de Ruby, on apprend la technologie à travers le jeu.
Par exemple, les ordinateurs sont très doués à répéter des choses.
La façon dont Ruby enseignerait les boucles est comme ça.
Voici la danse préférée de Ruby :
« Clappe, clappe, tape, tape, clappe, clappe et saute. »
On apprend le compteur de boucles en la répétant quatre fois.
Et on apprend les boucles while en répétant cette séquence,
pendant que je me tiens sur une jambe.
On apprend la boucle until en répétant cette séquence,
jusqu'à ce que maman soit vraiment en colère.
(Rires)
Et surtout, on apprend qu'il n'y a pas de réponses toutes faites.
Lorsque j'ai trouvé le programme éducatif pour le monde de Ruby,
j'avais besoin de demander aux enfants comment ils voyaient le monde
et quel genre de questions ils avaient,
et j'organisais des sessions de tests.
Je commençais en montrant aux enfants ces quatre images.
Je leur montrais l'image d'une voiture,
d'une épicerie, d'un chien et de toilettes.
Je leur demandais : « Lequel vous semble être un ordinateur ? »
Les enfants étaient très traditionnels et disaient :
« Aucun n'est un ordinateur.
Je sais ce qu'est un ordinateur :
c'est cette boîte brillante
devant laquelle maman ou papa passe beaucoup trop de temps. »
Mais nous parlions,
et nous découvrions qu'en fait, une voiture est un ordinateur.
Elle possède un système de navigation.
Et un chien — un chien n'est peut-être pas un ordinateur,
mais il a un collier,
et le collier pourrait avoir un ordinateur à l'intérieur.
Et les épiceries, elles ont tellement de types d'ordinateurs différents,
comme la caisse et les alarmes antivol.
Et les enfants, vous savez quoi ?
Au Japon, les toilettes sont des ordinateurs
et il y a même des pirates qui les piratent.
(Rires)
Nous allons plus loin,
et je leur donne ces autocollants avec un bouton on/off.
Je dis aux enfants : « Aujourd'hui, vous avez ce pouvoir magique
de transformer n'importe quoi dans cette pièce en ordinateur. »
Encore, les enfants disent :
« Ça a l'air vraiment dur, je n'ai pas la bonne réponse. »
Je leur dis : « Ne vous inquiétez pas,
vos parents n'ont pas non plus la bonne réponse.
Ils viennent tout juste d'entendre parler d'une chose
qui s'appelle « l'Internet des objets ».
Mais vous, les enfants, vous allez être ceux
qui vont vraiment vivre dans un monde où tout est un ordinateur. »
Puis cette petite fille est venue me voir,
elle a pris un phare de vélo
et elle a dit : « Ce phare de vélo, s'il était un ordinateur,
il changerait de couleur. »
J'ai dit : « C'est une très bonne idée. Il ferait quoi d'autre ? »
Elle réfléchit et réfléchit,
et elle dit : « Si ce phare de vélo était un ordinateur,
mon père et moi, on pourrait faire une randonnée en vélo,
et on dormirait dans une tente,
et ce phare pourrait aussi projeter des films. »
Et c'est le moment que j'attends,
le moment où l'enfant réalise
que le monde n'est définitivement pas encore prêt,
qu'une façon vraiment formidable de mieux préparer le monde
est de créer de la technologie,
et que chacun d'entre nous peut participer à ce changement.
L'histoire finale : nous avons aussi fabriqué un ordinateur.
Et nous avons rencontré l'autoritaire CPU, et les serviables RAM et ROM
qui l'aident à se rappeler des choses.
Après avoir assemblé notre ordinateur,
nous lui avons aussi créé une application.
Mon histoire préférée est ce petit garçon,
il a six ans,
et ce qu'il préfère par-dessus tout est d'être un astronaute.
Et le garçon, il a ces gigantesques écouteurs,
il est complètement plongé dans son petit ordinateur en papier,
parce que vous voyez, il a construit
sa propre application de navigation intergalactique et planétaire.
Et son père, l'astronaute solitaire dans l'orbite de Mars,
est de l'autre côté de la pièce,
et la mission importante du garçon
est de ramener son père sur Terre sain et sauf.
Avec la technologie, ces enfants vont avoir une vision du monde
et de la façon dont nous le construisons profondément différente.
Enfin, plus nous rendons le monde de la technologie
plus accessible, plus ouvert et plus divers,
meilleur et plus coloré sera le monde.
Imaginez donc avec moi, pendant un instant,
un monde où les histoires que nous racontons
sur la fabrication des objets incluent non seulement
les garçons de 20 ans de la Silicon Valley,
mais aussi les écolières kényanes et les bibliothécaires norvégiens.
Imaginons un monde où les petites Ada Lovelace de demain,
qui vivent dans une réalité de uns et de zéros permanente,
deviennent en grandissant très optimistes et courageuses face à la technologie.
Elles embrassent les pouvoirs, les opportunités
et les limites du monde.
Un monde de technologie qui est merveilleux, capricieux,
et un petit peu bizarre.
Quand j'étais petite fille,
je voulais raconter des histoires.
J'adorais les mondes imaginaires
et ce que je préférais,
c'était de me réveiller le matin dans la vallée des Moomins.
L'après-midi, je me promenais sur Tatooine.
Et la nuit, je m'endormais à Narnia.
La programmation s'est avérée être la parfaite profession pour moi.
Je crée encore des mondes.
Au lieu d'histoires, je les crée avec des programmes.
La programmation me donne ce pouvoir incroyable
de construire mon propre petit univers
avec ses propres règles, paradigmes et méthodes.
De créer quelque chose à partir de rien avec la puissance pure de la logique.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)